and nestor cortez towing the slab in the
boogie down here tonight you could see
on the season this will be his 12th
start and the numbers are really good
across the board a lot of love right
there go a slip out in right field by
judge and that one drops in for a base
hit isaiah with hit number 160
on the year
and this one hit sharply into right
field that's a base hit so back-to-back
singles to start the game tonight
connor felipe is at third ibanya is that
second nobody out just underway here at
the stadium swinging and miss got him on
a slider big strikeout for cortez
a nice one-two punch he came inside and
got him to pull a foul and you can see
the breaking ball spin right there comes
back door and then dives down gets
garcia to chase right over the top
strike three peters down looking two
away
and the payoff
swing and a miss houdini in the house
second and third nobody out he strikes
out garcia peters and lol aj alexey this
season it'll be now his third start
tonight in new york he's two and oh two
quick wins good era 3.68 14 and two
thirds inning so far a couple of home
runs allowed one two pitch
this one popped up
first base side playable for nathaniel
lowe one away
and he hits this one right into that
shift low is there he says don't don't
worry about it fellas i got it
two away
payoff pitch and that one misses the
mark badly judge draws the watch
and this one
out to center field it's to hang up a
little bit leone tavares gets to it and
the inning is done so here is nick zolac
to start off the top of the second
inning
grounded up the middle
torres backhands and fires strong to
first to get solace strike three
fine down looking
now the one-two swung on and lined a
left and caught by a diving
gallow dove
front wood face wood and made the grab
so one two three go the rangers end of
an ending and a half no score well that
is uh joey gallop and this is pregame
meeting some of his ex-mates he says
he's never played them before
as an opponent so you can see there's a
lot of respect and love there as he
leads off
and he tries to bunt and it's grabbed
beautifully by heim who turns that into
an out so two way that brings up gary
sanchez 3-1 swung on and hit in the deep
left that ball is gonna be gone
a line drive down the line into the
seats
gary sanchez
the kraken
cracks one all that gary is scary nehorm
is the left and the yankees take a
one-nothing lead there's a swing and a
dribbler out to the mound alexis got it
fires to first and the inning is over as
gardner is retired now one down and here
is le mayhew the pitch breaking balls
outside so lemayo is on with the one out
walk the two-two
line drive and face it into left center
field lemayo will stop at second so
rizzo goes the other way picks up a
single he's still one out first and
second we're in the bottom of the third
inning yankees lead one nothing now
here's aaron judge
and he lines one to left center field
there is a base head rounding third
lemay you coming home tavares a terrible
throw home goes past everyone so it's a
basin and an rbi for judge
lemay scores that's judge 86th rbi
second and third one out here is stanton
swung on and hit in the air to right
center that gets a run in
tavares makes the catch
the throw goes toward third
scoring is rizzo it's a sac fly and an
rbi for stanton
and the yankees take a three nothing
lead three-two
and gallow works a walk and here's glay
ratora's with chew on and chew out
line drive up basic to right field
charging is garcia
here comes judge and the throw is going
to come into second it's an rbi single
for torres and it's four-nothing yankees
well certainly a really nice swing from
glaber on a hanging slider that he's
able to recognize adjust and still take
this the other way a lot of hitters
would be way out in front of that pitch
2-2 and a swing in a minute strike three
so alexi
stayed in there and battled his way
through it and he strengths out gartner
the ending done go to the top of the
fourth inning so nestor cortes happily
has a four nothing lead
popped up
sanchez
makes the play and he avoids all of the
uh
paraphernalia on the on deck circle
tipped into the glove of sanchez two
away and it's low
so low walks
and another wall two straight two out
walks by cortez one two swing and a miss
went upstairs in the fastball
and gets out of the jam as we go to the
fifth inning it's charlie culberson
culberson lifts this one down the left
field line and that one is off the pole
a home run culverson's fifth home run of
the year and the rangers are on the
board
it's four to one he talked about it
earlier charlie culverson and the damage
that he has done against left-handed
pitching and it continues here tonight
in yankee stadium and what a bounce that
took off the foul pole think i've ever
seen that before it looked like it hit
and went up i mean that was
squared up on the pole
this ball hit pretty well out to the
alley and left field that one will get
down and bounce up into the rangers
bullpen there's a book rule double for
leote
rangers
making some adjustments here on nasty
nester now here is kind of valepa with a
runner at second no one out
this one on the ground that one is
through into right field base hit
tavares rounds third he'll score easily
heading to second base kinder philippa
and he has a double
the yankee lead has been cut in half
it's new york four and texas two
counterfeit with his 50th run batted in
the new pitcher is chad green
75 in the third innings he's given up 53
hits his problem has been the home run
ball and that pitch is outside all the
way to the backstop a wild pitch will
send connor falefa over to third base
2-2 pitch
this one
out to center field
hang up a little bit
for gardner tagging at third connor
falefa he'll come in and score and it's
a one-run game a sacked fly for a dolly
play holmes
will relieve chad greene who faced
five batters and retired them all
you see the numbers on holmes
with the pirates and the yankees this is
a 60
second game
swing and a miss
that power sinker 97 miles an hour the
bottom drops out of this one coming
right at you you can see the sinker spin
chopped right back to holmes
two down one two
is grounded weakly to first rizzo flips
to homes that ends the inning one two
three now here we go to the bottom of
the seventh inning
ground it oh knocked down and then off
the glove of low hits so hard he just
could not hold on
we'll see how they score it as judge
reaches
here's a swing and a miss and joey will
strike out here for the second out in
the inning now it's up to patton to keep
this game exactly where it is right now
give the rangers a chance to win it
this ball blind is short and right there
for it is kinder fuller the inning is
over chapman tries to pick up his 28th
save so he is 56 game 87 strikeouts and
50 in the third innings
wade did that pitch in the dirt
throw to first strikeout and the pitch
grounded to third lemay who gobbles it
up across the diamond they just get
culberson hustling down the line and the
rangers are down to their final out
deals the 2-2
swing and a miss got him and the stare
is back as the yankees win this one 4-3
to start off this three-game set with a
victory
you